[Music]
this is a new Tom Petty and the
Heartbreakers song and never-before-seen
footage of him and his band you're
watching it for the first time here on
CBS this morning the song is called keep
a little soul it is the first Tom Petty
music to be released since his death
last October Anthony Mason is here with
how the new song and video footage were
discovered Anthony good morning good
morning Tom Petty kept an extensive
archive and early this year when his
family began pulling tapes from storage
they found a trove of unreleased
recordings among them some vintage gems
like keep a little soul
Hevy recorded the song in 1982 during
the sessions for the long after dark
album it didn't make the cut then but
the family felt the words resonate today
[Music]
keep a little soul we'll be on a new 60
track box set an American treasure
to be released in September a career
spanning retrospective designed to
highlight petty skills as a songwriter
songs for about 20 years with this
guitar only which he talked about in a
2009 interview for CBS Sunday morning
do you know when you've written a good
song not always the bees are the
dangerous things you know because they
can some kind they could look like a
yeah
and when did they finally reveal
themselves well in the recording yeah
you get you get a little if your be
sitting right next to an a uh-huh it
just can't pull it off
[Music]
the American treasure project was
commissioned by Petty's wife Dana and
daughter Adria the criteria Adri told
Adria told me were songs that we all
felt really said something about dad
it's such a strange thing to lose
someone like him he was much cooler than
people could imagine and I think a lot
of people thought he was pretty cool
yeah when did they start putting this
collection because this really has the
family said it took them a while to face
the music about Tom's death obviously
and and they began putting this together
after the Grammys earlier this year they
called up recordings from from the
archive some of them they literally had
to bake in an oven because they were on
tape and get them transferred and they
found this extraordinary tale they
listened to about 50 unreleased songs
there are a dozen of them on this album
and they said there's actually a lot
more in there they really just started
this process but they wanted to put
something out that was intimate that was
in their words between the hits there
are live recordings here there are
alternate takes of classic songs and
there are as I said about a dozen
unreleased some previously unreleased
songs it's already at the top of my
summer playlist it's a great circuit
when you use where is this been where
has it been Anthony always good to see
you
[Music]